let me know how it goes i will
all right i think a lot of people want
to be outdoors with this beautiful
weather too and that may be a little
challenging with the wind that's coming
back today
we've got gorgeous sunshine back you
know those high clouds were with us all
day yesterday
but look at the breezes already blowing
the palm trees around
these southerly winds on the increase
already especially for south valley
neighborhoods
already they've been up over 15 miles an
hour look at the 50s
it is so mild outside feels great
and we're going to get another warm day
today will be our warmest though for the
rest of the eight day forecast
don't forget we do spring forward in the
daylight saving time this weekend
it's always the second sunday of march
so don't forget to set your clocks ahead
one hour on saturday night when you go
to bed
sunrise sunday will be 6 52 a.m
and 6 47 will be the sunset so all the
high clouds from yesterday
shifting to the east out of the area and
we'll start to see
by tomorrow if not by later tonight some
high clouds
ahead of this next big colder system
which is really going to plummet our
temperatures by the middle of the week
bring us a chance for showers and some
good mountain snow
we're looking for mid 70s today gusty
winds 25
30 miles an hour and tomorrow could be
35 plus
still think the weather service national
weather service might issue some wind
advisories
for tomorrow we're going to watch for
that 30 percent chance of some showers
wednesday and then especially for the
owens valley
maybe southeast california some very low
snow levels thursday morning
maybe not for the valley here in las
vegas but we'll see much colder though
highs in the mid 50s by thursday and
then back slowly we creep to some 60s
nice mid to upper 60s through the
weekend